can you can everybody hear me in the
back [ __ ] good all right so yes my
name is charged the trio I work at the
Lawrence Livermore National Laboratory
and this is playa de San Francisco to
this 14 2016 and I'm going to talk about
you can Oh ready you know breaking
everything no can you get me better like
that no they can't hear me this one is
it better this one okay perfect all
right sir that over the my name is
charges he ho kinda work at Lawrence
Livermore National Lab oh baby now c
walk there oh ok I can hold it I don't
mind alright and so I'm going to talk
about this new project we having which
is a virtual laboratory to the vision
for more earth science collaborative any
stupid environment virtual labs and so I
put a few names of my team at Livermore
but that's a really really big project
has been going on for a lot of time it's
a military agencies its international
and its a mix of universities labs you
know private sectors everything is a
about 30 logos here and I probably
forgot a bunch of them just had to cram
as much as possible in there so it's a
it's projects been going on for as a me
to show in my history corn nuts it's
been going on for a long time so i will
go over try to give you the background
because i don't think as many people
here in the field and then i took about
the ultra scale visualization climate
that analysis tours which is more like
on compute part and talk about the earth
system grid federation which is a data
center sort of trying to give you the
nitty-gritty and then I go and unload
fusing all that and creating a virtual
laboratory so a brief story about
pissing VI which is a program for
climate model data
and intel corporation she's almost an
acronym at need an acronym pc MDI it's
been created in we have to go back in
about an hour 1989 and at the time there
was a bunch of already climate model so
centers running all over the world but
they were all basically living in
isolation doing their own model and they
all claimed they were the best in the
world and you know they were very good
at what they were doing but each model
was more center of the world looking at
different aspects of science that they
were interested in so they're really
good at bat so in 89 the do a department
of energy created this kind of
independent rabbit fur abitur and just
to try to get the commune scientific
community together and like evaluate
this model because at the time lag
wasn't very hot yet but they decided to
realize that with global warming thing
well maybe was something should look
into you know what so we should know how
good these models hard to predict these
things so that was the whole idea and
Pete India was created and it was a just
to evaluate the models but we didn't
have any model so that was we could be
like completely objective because we're
like okay we're just going to look at
you guys and try to tell you you know
what you could do better and it was a
joint effort between research scientist
or actually scientists you know on the
science part of you and computer
scientist it was actually 221 lat to
computer scientist for each scientist at
the time so to to help the scientists
focus on the science and the computer
scientists to give them the tool to do
what they needed to do their research so
that is nice and so few years later you
know take a time coordinate with these
people and that led to the first ever
international global atmospheric
meditech conversion project which
basically was between everybody okay you
hold up your greater greatest model ever
we're going to ask you we're going to
give you the initial set of boundary
conditions which the sea surface
temperature for about 10 years and
you're going to run your model with the
same kind of input because everybody is
our
two weeks so that everybody's going to
run the same thing run it for ten years
and then we're just going to do but if
you don't I was really hard to actually
get them to do that convince the people
to just walk together because everybody
was kind of scared about the you know
it's at work great day music yeah i
don't know i really want to compare and
stuff so and we sort of we looked at
what i think in the end wins zaryadye
wasn't working there yet and turns out
that we discovered this common cold
buyers across all the models so which is
very clear on 200 hectopascals I mean
atmosphere there's a really cool like
older model were way way way too cool
compared to observe Asians and everybody
knew that that every mothers are like
yeah we searched their that's okay so
you know we were so good everything else
and then this thing came out and all
like oh my god it's like everybody
actually nobody can do that so they
realized I was actually a fundamental
issue it was just say my dad was a prima
debt so we have some parametrizations
something that was wrong and that that
was actually or drove work for us
because I don't know that everybody got
super excited because their mother with
so much better from that and realizing
lag oh it was actually some value to
collaborate this is not just going to be
a ranking operation it's just going to
really help us make better model and
find in other things so we lucked out on
bad I've ever met things much easier and
in the future to get people to go into
the project because now they knew that
there was an actual value to that I've
do a quick digression about model
development just for the ring and at the
origin of you know climate atmosphere
atomic model but as pretty much like
this kind of thing was really done to
just simulating the Atlas air shows
basically air rise and drops down around
30 degree which is what you have like
it's dry and I told you have most of the
desert in the planet out there and that
was really bare bone basic some new
equations and then you know as computer
get better and the scientists get better
and without a at a more parameterization
and there's like this is kind of a
typical now atmospheric model so you
introduce you know aerosol and clouds
and ozone and you have your input and
output of energy and the greenhouse gas
and all that and how much
the ground is an absorbing heat things
like that and then it goes even more
crazy because now you don't just look
just as atmospheric well the ocean is
very important and then you have
chemistry in the ocean chemistry in the
atmosphere you avoid precipitation and
you have run off mother and I Sigma
dares and all kind of Madeline it's all
like together and that's what we could
coupled model so Zach thousand and
thousand of different physics equations
put together a modernization and so vis
medela run at some very specialized
centers with a lot of obviously computer
power so that's to give you an idea so
Amy it was super success we are they
need to and then people are like okay
okay that's cool so now we all like have
an idea with these models are but again
we he'd like to try to think about you
know global warming and come back in the
future so lucky this model actually good
at I mean maybe they're really good at
simulating the climate now but can they
actually outdo the behave in a totally
different environment so there's been
simulation like pee nib which is
paleoclimate model intercomparison
project and we use basically i score and
trees and things I've had to figure out
the climate of the last glacial maximum
Bo 25,000 years ago or so k matters very
different and we try to random bodeli in
these conditions so that give us more
information and so a lot of this meep
started to create together you know just
to evaluate the model because it was
very important that we want to know why
these models you know how good they are
and other acts tables so now the couple
models they do with crazy finger showed
earlier which ocean sea is nano zone
chemistry ocean chemistry everything
together and that led to the internal
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change assistant reported five which
leads to go treaties such as accurate
treaty which lead to policymakers being
able to actually do informed decisions
so it's very important to get them with
the right I never win preparation for
similar six because we as a system type
in every like six seven years you know
physically state of the heart of the
science in earth so not to say there was
like lot of lesson learned during better
about 20-30 years
what do you say I guess so like for
example for the first project Amy there
was some data but we just could never
even read like this send us a binary
thing and we just couldn't look at it we
couldn't read it this send us even the
code we couldn't compile the code and
stuff so you know second around we're
like okay we're going to give you some
tools to rewrite the data as but this
would be able to to read them back in
and so as this process go around and get
better we have all off set of tools in
house for our scientists which means
more and more democratized and being
using across the community so that's
where see that okay Matt detinan sister
said was what's created or underline and
set of 2 so 4 f's aunt is basically then
the semi pecan and we realized that we
had to have some convention because
everybody at front data and weirdin em
pie and we create the earth system grid
to which I will come back later now he
talks all about the UVC dad which is the
trust scale visualization climate
analysis tools and that basically or
analysis statically kind of think of it
as maybe like the name focus of f
science or something like that so it was
as i mentioned born for more in a house
set of tools and run 96 which is when i
started to work there i would you say to
use python other blue for all these
tools because i find is awesome i know
that it's really really good actually at
talking to see and all these other
language so we do that and we have all
these tools now to analyze and visualize
like big climate model simulations and
also observations and it's mainly for
lab for do ii labs nasa and NOAA two
universities and to private companies
but work on the on the call and what the
core obviously at the quarry second
phase of basically numerics which is
obviously an empire if you're in python
you've been twisting pie and we have
CDMS to the climate data management
system which is doing all the iOS and we
have our announce like really custom
tools for scientists which is climate
data utilities and genital which are
more general
utilities for just manipulating arrays
kind of things and we have VCS which is
a visual control system to do Joe based
data so to get done just online final
digression on that okay it's great we
have all this data so we like okay let's
just use numpy because we start to try
to implement our own you know math
operators and step and it will get
started to suck so much overtime just to
implement better life look it's fing Qin
Empire is here actually was numeric we
used before them pay exists but then we
switch it to numpy and that buys great
it's awesome it's really fast and where
they took from James Powell earlier
explain you why you should use it so
it's great but for us it's the first
just not quite enough numpy itself
because we are reproducing actual reward
data not just the motet we're comparing
to the observations and if you sub
salvation you mean missing data because
you know like your instruments died for
like two weeks and somebody had to go
and reprimanded plement it and stuff so
we needed and then pi came with ma which
is awesome for us which is masquerade so
like okay now we know how to deal with
our reserve as new data and then find as
bad for us so that is good but that's
still not enough because what you have
out of numpy and ma is just numbers I
mean sin array it's just a bunch of
numbers and that's great but if you want
to do a like a software suit and that's
bad really like off strength you know
stuff is that we try to integrate all
our tools and make them work together
and okay I have numbers and what can I
do with that I mean it's you know I'm
just going to give it to my next set of
suit and Zack I don't know give me
numbers what you want me to do with it
but we introduced with notions of
metadata and dimensional information
that I associated with the data so
that's weak will mask variable and
variable as in addition to just the
numbers we give them domain information
so for example you know it's afridi
array and dimension one is latitude
dimension 2 is gratitude and we also
have vertical informations so now like
if I pass back to my next to a part of
my suits it's like oh okay it's actually
like her kind of data i can plug that i
can do things for you automatically I
can you know project it on on the globe
or do a subset you know based on your
region things I bet
you already leave it forever but you
still need more like what is it okay
it's geo data and I'm going to look at
it like oh it's it's probably a
temperature but temperature of what or
so we have all this notion of metadata
and that's like super important when to
try to hammer that the metadata is pro
reason most important part is that
documentation of what it is you're
plotting and that enables your software
to make a lot of very smart decisions
for the scientists really helps them to
do the right thing and help the
scientist focus on on the science and
much less than the data cleaning then
things divad so the metadata i give you
the units it gives you the name it tells
you you know which experiment is coming
from which motors been running that a
lot of things that you can actually help
your software to do the sensory smart so
because we have the metadata now we
could develop a very much better climate
data management system which is IO and
that make us allows us to do smart tools
because we are all these models they
whole come you know a different
resolution depending on the computation
power of the center of the running at
and so somewhere that I like you know
man on over 20 by 20 data and somewhere
like 200 x 200 like very high resolution
or like 360 x 180 s if you run into
degree even worse now and so you want to
get your data and look at them over the
same array of the world and now we can
just say okay with me open that file and
read me the clouds and I just interested
let me know in the tropics at minus
twenty to twenty minutes for it Ferdie
and yes I would like you know to have
from 0 to 360 and from minus 180 to 180
because everybody starts it differently
and oh yes I'm only interested in these
three years here and because i made a
data are in the file and the file
basically self to command it we can do
that in one line like as you see here i
just say okay I want this area and I've
at Texas I mean if you don't have it
made editors going to take you a lot of
line of codes and it's going to make
your code super nut general like oh if
Modell a get index you know 12 24 the
time but if its model too because this
one is more data get it a little bit
earlier and later things like that so it
was basically these tools that are
really
helping the the scientist to do io is
Allah and then p 0 again focus on just
what it is you need and then okay you've
got your data in and so we have all
these packages which is climate data
utilities and generic utilities data and
because we were working hand in hand
with the scientist we could develop all
these things a lot of specific tools are
changing units creating departures you
know basic stack basically for them
doing regrading because it's not very
easy to go from you know Calvin entire
grid to a reckoner agreed because they
all have different resolution as I say
section to the difference you need to
make sure we both physically line and
match together the article interpolation
and then again all our i/o of using
these conventions so we rewrite it we
can use it in another package it will
have all the history and the provenance
and all these things design with you so
you did your analysis now using these
tools and now we have the visitation
control system this year's which gives
you publication quality and output and
it's really like targeted for like earth
science again and as you can see here in
like five lines of code you can actually
really need it and put them on you know
any we know it's the earth which is not
necessarily easy to do in our packages
just like Matt lately so all that was
nice or biggest challenge for the
longest time was okay we're using Python
and it's great and we kind of comments
people to use Python but distributing
that thing was just hell because they
were like a 300 Wharf megabyte of
sources to compile and it had to work on
every machine and when I am I talking
here but I have a pretty much like a bad
match key chain of tokens of machining
and login just because for the longest
time fifty percent my java just to go
install that on the supercomputers for
everybody and everybody was like AI love
yourself to as great but it's just you
know i can't use it because it's going
to take me you know six months for for
interaction with you to get it on a
system which is not very true but let's
as our reputation and and so thank you
very much to Conda like I cannot thank
them enough ever made my life so much
easier and now in one line I can just
say like go get data in standard
software and people can use it
and so that is good because now we
really have the full power of Python
which people are convinced by now like
everybody agrees that iphone is great
but they were always complaining about
like my after eyes inside your Python
the time we're using matlab and i'm
using you know our PI and all these
things and you don't come with it
because videos to have to install
already we've ordered software we had so
we do distributive Matt Bradley but
elephant in the room cause everybody's
using that here and we're giving like
pie tables all these things now you can
do it so we have a basically a really
good ecosystem and the strength of this
ecosystem is been really all over to
that we develop they really work nicely
together so you can go back sir
scientists can really go from reading in
the data to analyzing them hurting them
and saving them and it all works
together nicely and as and I was really
really happy to listen to like James
powers token think was gonna miss you
turn on Friday when you mentioned but
then focus is really trying to get this
direction now but they're trying to get
order to to really work better together
and live with less friction when you go
from one to another settings freaks and
I'm really happy about that because
that's always you know you jump and your
data are not quite ready for the next
step and you're more prosperous listings
anyway but take us to the second set of
tools that were distributing which is
Earth System rich Federation so as I
mentioned most of these and all these
tools have been developed in the context
of analyzing model data and with each
iteration and more room power from the
computers and all state the strip your
computer you know the labs are very
happy to a bigger and bigger computers
and the scent is like how more power
yeah I can just double mayor you know
resolution of my data I even put some
time it doesn't make any sense
physically anymore because some
abstention are not true anyway we have
more and worried about two other of a
magnitude more of data with every
iteration of the project so very quickly
like we originally we used to just
basically host to data and have people
turn out them for a are five the last
process it will realize that like now
there's nowhere we can host in-house we
don't have even though we're like a goe
lab and web
like pretty much in limited hardware and
computers we want we just can't hold
that much data and have everybody come
in hiring and for the next duration
review and Wars not something we can't
hold it as an institution we we can't
like it's going to take too long for
people to even download them so the
prime of distribution of the data that's
been done up our system grid and what we
decided to do with that well it's just
too big so let's keep the data that
serves the data from where they are
generated biblically so we created this
Federation of data nodes when you
generate your data and you just open it
to the word with notification of course
and things like that so now we don't
have to constantly bring everything to
the one single institution there was a
core set of a sub data that was analyzed
you know like identified for yeah there
are five and this corset was replicated
at a few centers but in general most of
the data state whereas they were
produced so what's the node look like
and no Duke like Erica don't know the
node manager sorry and the compute node
and the data notice at the data and an
index and so all there is no talk
together so now we have a single point
of entry for the user it just looks like
a big fat clouds basically we just
reinvented like a federated cloud of
loads of data and people can inquiry
download visualize the data they want
and we also do that aggregation because
this file I get in different chunks so
it looks like one big data set and we
have user notification service because
you know it's still like like there's
always case where you download this data
and then a year later somebody found a
bug in the simulation so that all we
need to update the simulation you know
something need and we'll walk in the
first process so then we get the user
like oh by the way you might want to
rerun anything because they'd have been
updated cleaned up a bit or maybe
there's more data available to you now
I've been processed so that led to
things like quality control and we have
three levels of quality control we have
level one which is like you produce your
data you think it's good enough to be
and distribute it to the ward so that's
quite a level control one and then when
we're going to replicate this data go to
the primary center so your data has been
identified of like core valuable we have
more checks you go to choir centers and
then when you go to the publication
level agency it should level for even
more screening on the data then you get
a DOI so you can use it in your research
and it's very important because do is
important because it takes a lot of
resources to produce this data I mean a
lot of computers and a lot of time and
not have hardware so they like to get
credit for people using the data so it's
not a good it's corey ball and you know
it showed that a lot of people are
actually using visitor that wasn't
completely waste of money thank you
sponsors so it's a wrap some great is a
really really really big project it's
like i just listed here about 18
subgroups and we deal with every part of
their life of the data from you know
publishing it with yellow tube with
security and resource allocations
quality control replication i mean
there's like a lot it's a really big
system so where it goes to and I kind of
a hint it too bad the earth system grid
is okay in the last instance we already
realized we couldn't host everything in
a single institution anymore but now
it's worse but it's to the point but
like even if it's distributed it's going
to be so big force for similar sticks
that if you're a scientist and you're
like oh I want to look at like you know
three or four different Bibles and I'm
just going to run my classic analysis on
it we're going to take about if you just
do the normal style matter of
downloading it even to your institution
as a musician can hold that mentioned
that for like a year or two off of data
and you pretty much out of a job by the
time you know your page is going to be
10 years now so you can do your PhD so
what we need to do we need to move out
of this concept of getting the people to
remember that you don't download the
data and get them used to let's bring
the code to the data because we want
very very very little movement data so
that's that's why we add so bad bring is
to be new project oh sorry you want
I believe that for you all right okay so
that brings us to the virtual
laboratories which is because we have a
hand in with to project that and we had
the core of both of them when I we
really have is two great thing just just
make it like really work together now we
can we have the code we have the data
let's just create this virtual
environment so the scientists can
actually work with this data because
it's so much value to it and that's lead
us to the computer working team and so
as i mentioned we're going to bring the
code there and our goal is to basically
get the code to the data where the data
is at using you know clusters or extreme
scale basically next using distributed
that are quick computing centers we're
going to use so see that which is
actually being renamed the community
that analysis tools now because we're
really broadening to out of just earth
sciences we're trying to reach out to
you know bio and things like that and we
had to talk yesterday about you know flu
and you can really link this to kind of
data you know flu and waiver and things
like that so it's not the community but
anyway it's going to be basically the
core like to run the computation on this
on the server side we're hoping to but
we went for an extension of weather of
web process services to do our API so it
was the first part we have this API
which is really language agnostic we
just wanted to know more okay let's give
aware for people to tell like I am
interested in studying this data and do
that so it's it's complete man completed
agnostic or whatever and back and
implementation you want it's just we
added a few things that we need for our
data you're going to go do it and
implement it on the server side and we
also of course because because its web
processing you end up with like Earl
which are about that being a bad loan
like 20 data set and things so we have
Python
user and API as well so you can just you
know script it and command-line it and
think that I bad so that part is pretty
much done as far as fast a p.i goes we
were pretty happy about version 1 of the
API and we of course more iteration
coming in the features and the next part
luck really coming up now is the
implementation of the server back and
we're very things and there's so much we
want to do like first of all we want to
add different ways to implement the same
kind of algorithm because just I mean we
had PI data and we see it it's always
new techniques and new things going and
so we want to be you know able to use
all these techniques we can beat that
MPI or phidias project in Italy or spark
or whatever it is you can implement it
different ways and let the user decide
which way they would like I want API to
still work so that's parts pretty good
but we also need to leverage from the
rest of the system grid Federation
people seems like we don't want to
reinvent identification security you
know data allocations and things like
that now in the future like the really
exciting part that is for the server
side is to do all these Auto smartness
about like where to run the code because
it's nice to bring the code to the data
but since the data is distributed and
everywhere like where do we really send
the code to because and data and maybe
maybe at two different centers and like
one is like a super fast computer and
you're like oh yeah I should run it
there because it's been to run my own
stimulation in like 15 minutes but it
turned out like oh you're in the queue
and you're not going to run for number
two days where language over sentara me
maybe it will take like three hours to
join but hey I'm first in the queue so
maybe you should run it there and don't
know the data back and we still be
faster than waiting for the super fast
computer to let me go into Q so that
always kind of like machine learnings
and things like that are very exciting
that we're going to do and it's
basically starting now and on the other
end is that ok so now we have the
distributed data we have the server-side
computation but we still need the
scientists to work together and you know
be able to do the analysis is
II so we have this vision of 44 BC that
which is the decay window on top of this
computer server and it's very similar
like as it was like looking at it and
everything something kind of like
Jupiter labs where you can come in call
your data look at your data do scrubber
analysis locally we hopefully you can be
collaborative to that we're hoping to
select scientists in Iraq here can also
work with scientists in Germany or
scientists in Australia you can all work
together see what the interesting and
work together it will help us also give
provenance and openness and
reproducibility because it's very you
know that now climate change is very
political so you need to make sure that
you're super clear super clean like
everything is here and reproducible so
nobody can attack you so a bad project
is also just coming up to speed up the
VC that thing so the summary who have
years and years and you have been of
tools investment in in the domain we
have two strong systems i think for data
distribution and that analysis that are
finally getting together and being
integrated it's open source all of it
completely open source it's easy to grow
and add on it and it's very early in the
process so like if you are excited about
any kind of these things we just love to
have more people joined to the
contribute and contribute we expanding
beyond the herb sciences which restrain
like I said bio may be overfilled as
well always looking for feedback from
the community like what do you use that
why don't you use this new things that's
also why would the conference where to
learn about what else we should do okay
that slide is more at for later when you
go download it so you can go look at all
this thing we're doing and it's about
it's just ready to take your questions
now thank you
questions
so some of the new models use on
structured grids compared to a lot of
the structured grid does represent of
any challenges for use for like
integrating impasse for instance into
your frameworks yes it is prone to look
so the question was like about the new
type of grades and submit six will have
a lot of that and structured grades are
things I bad and yes it presents
challenges but but we have to at least a
reg reader for now as a first thing but
let us go from a [ __ ] to any grid that
we use the earth system modeling
framework recruiter and that lets you
too bad lots of / solution but we're
trying to ream him and to as well to
walk as much as possible directly on the
native grades at these tools are coming
out slowly most of them come from the
ocean community because they've been
dealing with this we are great for a
long time so so we're getting the tools
from them as well and bring them in
okay there are no more questions thank
you thanks Chelse oh thanks wait